les autobus scolaires de vos enfants
sont ils vraiment sécuritaire
quand l'autobus est tombé à du monde y
avait des bouts de vie comme partout sur
le corps puissante celle ci se fait plus
40 ans que les ceintures de sécurité
sont obligatoires dans nos voitures mais
pendant les autobus scolaires
pourquoi il y avait plus d'enjeu quoi
finissent par aller peut-être d andré ce
qui risque d'être sérieuses difficultés
financières
est ce que c'est une question de
sécurité ou une question d'argent
nous avons des révélations troublantes
et plus tard à l'émission des auteurs
d'attentats
d'attac chimiques et même d'assassinât
qui sont démasqués par de simples
citoyens qui décortique des vidéos sur
le web
les citoyens qui téléchargent ces
contenus veulent que le monde entier
sache que ce qu'ils vivent est bien réel
et que ce n'est pas faux alès note
faible
bienvenue à enquête
[Musique]
avez vous déjà ressenti une certaine
crainte envoyant vos enfants vos petits
enfants montés à bord d'un autobus
scolaire en vous demandant comment
s'assurer qu'ils sont pas attachés dans
l'autobus alors qu'on porte la ceinture
de sécurité
systématiquement dans nos voitures avec
nos collègues de l'émission fifth estate
on a découvert que l' agence fédérale
qui a la responsabilité nous protège et
transports canada nous a caché pendant
longtemps des informations cruciales
le scénario catastrophe un camion qui
roule
r un autobus scolaire en panne une
collision inévitable et brutale
heureusement il ne s'agit que d'un test
pour vérifier l'efficacité des ceintures
de sécurité
regardez les mannequins qui sont
attachés il reste bien assis ceux qui ne
portent pas de ceinture sont violemment
éjecté du véhicule
et c'est effectivement ce qui se produit
trop souvent dans la vie
[Musique]
comme ici sur une route de campagne de
l'alberta en 2008
un camion chargé de gravier frappe de
plein fouet un autobus scolaire
invisible dans le brouillard le
brouillard était tellement dense qu'on
ne pouvait pas voir les poteaux jenny la
fille de john ont beau y avait 17 ans à
cette dernière année du secondaire elle
attendait son bal de graduation et son
entrée à l'université avec impatience je
les accompagnais l'autobus ce matin là
je me suis rendu au travail à la caserne
de pompiers le chef du service a dit il
ya eu un accident d'autobus scolaires
j'ai tout de suite dit c'est l'autobus
de jenny il m'a dit on ne sait pas
encore mais je le savais d'un an avait
raison il s'agissait bien de l'autobus
de sa fille jenny avait été projeté de
la banquette arrière sur la route
asphaltée
il n'y avait pas de ceinture de sécurité
je me demande vraiment pourquoi la
ceinture n'est pas encore devenu
obligatoire dans tous les types de
véhicules
[Musique]
tous les jours au canada 40000 autobus
scolaire transporte environ deux
millions d'enfants vers l'école
[Musique]
et la grande majorité ne sont pas munis
de ceintures de sécurité comme celui ci
qui transportent les élèves de l'école
saint joseph de sainte-adèle au nord de
montréal
ils ont tous une histoire à raconter le
taux puisse rouler il y avait une grosse
boîte
par contre la route et du coup ça a
beaucoup bougé il ya moins une hymne à
lyon n'est tombé à terre ils m'ont été
vu seul à tourner la bringue route rule
qui a le but corey mans et on a tout un
volet on arrive en arrière j'ai fait une
cogné la tête sur une ville
mais avait de la glace partage le la
times taille dans le fossé il est
prestement à combler leur part ça tu pas
peur que si je faisais les deux jeunes
aimeraient mieux avoir une ceinture de
sécurité et en même temps parce qu'en
même temps on est plus sur les bords
dans ta bulle on dit que le transport en
autobus scolaire est parmi les plus
sécuritaires
peut-être mais les collisions ont fait
des milliers de blessés et plusieurs
décès au canada au cours des derniers
dix ans et au québec le nombre
d'accidents d'autobus scolaires avec
blessures a augmenté de 15% entre 2012
et 2016
aurait-on pu en éviter au moins une
partie avec l'expérience je trouve que
c'est vraiment important du goût la
sécurité pour les enfants mais aussi
pour lui tout prix le gist entre la
prochaine de trottoirs les jeunes
yonnais 3,4 en revue les leurs parce que
même dans les études on and well et
ceintures de sécurité fille pourquoi pas
les autres besoins elle restait vraiment
moi depuis 40 ans transports canada
l'autorité fédérale en matière de
sécurité routière nous encourage à
boucler la ceinture de sécurité en
voiture mais pas dans les autobus
scolaires
l'agencé affirme qu'au contraire la
ceinture dans les autobus n'est pas
nécessairement plus sécuritaire elle
pourrait même aggraver des blessures à
l'origine de cette thèse un test de
collision mené par transports canada en
vérification finale les caméras sont
chargées les mannequins en place des
autobus rempli de mannequins sont
projetés directement contre un mur
la collision est violente et c'est
l'office national du film qu'il a tourné
selon cette étude de transports canada
un système de banquettes coussiné appelé
compartimentation protège les enfants
sans qu'ils aient à porter la ceinture
de sécurité
le dossier eau etc à pitonner absorbent
l'énergie de l'impact et d'après l'agent
sle ceinture ventrale pourrait provoquer
des blessures au cou des enfants en cas
de collision frontale un violent recul
de la tête peut causer de graves
blessures ou la mort
depuis cette étude est la plus largement
cité en amérique du nord
ici elle est invoquée par la société
d'assurance-automobile lé fabricant
d'autobus et les transporteurs scolaires
le message se veut simple et rassurant
les autobus scolaires sont sécuritaires
ce qu'on dit à nogent le système qu'on a
présentement de compartimentation faire
en sorte qu'on a de moins en moins de
blessés qu'on avait dans les deux cas la
force est d'admettre que le système
qu'on a en place et c'est efficace ce
côté là un discours repris aussi par les
politiciens et des organismes comme le
conseil canadien de la sécurité invoque
les mêmes arguments
la conception même des autobus scolaires
rend le port de la ceinture de sécurité
inutiles et dans certains cas plus
dangereux vous vous appuyez sur quelles
preuves celle de transports canada vous
parlez du test de transports canada de
exact
cette étude est devenu la référence est
fait en sorte que des dizaines de
millions d'enfants en amérique du nord
ne porte toujours pas la ceinture dans
les autobus scolaires
notre enquête démontre toutefois que
l'étude en question comporte de sérieux
problèmes et que d'autres études
contradictoires ont été menées depuis
mai qu elles ont été gardées secrètes
[Musique]
depuis la fameuse étude de 1984 on
compte au moins deux douzaines de décès
au canada dans des accidents impliquant
des autobus scolaires
plus d'une centaine aux états unis et
plus de 140000 blessures dans les deux
pays donnent robben en ontario en 1999
regina en 2006 mont-saint-hilaire en
[Musique]
ces images de caméras de surveillance
illustre ce qui se passe à l'intérieur
des autobus scolaires pendant un
accident les images parlent de demain
pourtant transports canada continue
d'affirmer que les ceintures de sécurité
ne protège pas toujours les enfants et
peuvent même causé des blessures
mais parlez-en à ceux qui ont vécu des
accidents de ce genre
moi j'étais assise côté gauche
et puis j'ai entendu deux tours 2-3 fait
un en-avant crier monsieur attention
j'ai vu la voiture à lansargues lui
arrive est rentré dans l'autobus
littéralement
mont-saint-hilaire mai 2016
une course à très grande vitesse entre
deux voitures en pleine banlieue une des
deux frappent violemment le côté de
l'autobus scolaire qui tentait de
traverser le boulevard sous la force de
l'impact
l'autobus se renverse
pour vous donner une idée l'autobus
était penché comme ça c'est juste
vraiment tendu le gros boom qui est je
me suis ramassée à terre avec la tête en
sang virginie riel et gabriel gélinas
deux anciens élèves du collège
saint-hilaire
donc j'ai tombé de haut jusqu'en bas
jusque dans flight est opposé mais je me
suis quand même comme frappé la taille
sur le bord de la fin qu'est ce qui
s'est passé avec les fenêtres et les
vitres
quand l'autobus est tombée on tout
éclate eur puis à du monde il y avait
des bouts de vitres dans un peu partout
sur le corps ça veut dire une lacération
environ 5 cm puis ça ça pissait le sang
oui j'avais jeunes comme sont sévères
après une commotion cérébrale moutète
des problèmes de concentration
virginie n'a pas pu faire ces examens de
fin d'études
d'autres élèves ont eu des membres
cassés ou des chocs post traumatique les
gens tu n as qu elle est à tout le monde
était plus je crois sous le choc le
monde arabe elle n'en revenait pas qu'un
autobus a pu tomber comme ça puis ça
nous arrive à nous comme ça le bilan
aurait pu être pire
comme pour cet accident survenu au texas
en 2006 une équipe de soccer en chemin
vers une partie éliminatoire à houston
il pleut la route est glissante et
l'autobus fait une embardée
je me suis retrouvé étendu sur la route
j'étais sous le choc comme si c'était la
guerre
les gens étaient couverts de sang
c'était le cas au sahara est projeté sur
l'asphalté
son corps est écorchée jusqu'à l'os les
cicatrices en témoigne toujours dans
l'autobus s'est renversée on est toutes
tombées l'une par dessus l'autre j'ai
été traîné sur l'as fait
si nous avions été attachées et ce
serait une toute autre histoire
[Musique]
sarah s'en est sorti mais pas sa
meilleure amie ashley brown décédé dans
l'accident qui a aussi gravement blessé
sa coéquipière allison forman
douze ans plus tard leurs pairs sont
toujours en colère ils ont passé une
décennie à militer pour rendre les
ceintures de sécurité dans les autobus
obligatoire parce que personne n'en est
sorti sans blessure ma fille est morte
dans cet accident
elle a été éjecté de son siège et tué
instantanément
nos filles ont été éjectés de leurs
sièges parce qu'elle ne portait pas de
ceinture ça nous a poussés à faire des
recherches au sujet du transport en
autobus scolaires et en autocar au cours
de leur combat ils ont découvert que les
transporteurs et les commissions
scolaires mener leur propre bataille
l'industrie du transport en autobus nous
a profondément dégoûté on s'est rendu
compte que les agences gouvernementales
choisissent les études et les
statistiques qui leur conviennent
curieusement transports canada avait
déjà prévu il ya quarante ans de rendre
obligatoires les ceintures de sécurité
dans les autobus scolaires les
l'industrie du transport scolaire s'est
mobilisée contre le projet fabricants et
transporteurs ont multiplié les
représentations auprès de transports
canada leur principal argument le
rapport coût/bénéfice l'augmentation de
la sécurité et donc du coût des autobus
en valait-il vraiment la peine
transports canada a rapidement abdiqué
les autobus scolaires ne serait
finalement pas équipés de ceintures de
sécurité
les prétextes invoqués steve et bradent
les ont tous entendu les enfants ne
savent pas comment boucler la ceinture
où il pourrait s'en servir comme arme
on a même voulu comparer l'autobus à une
boîte à heuhh les enfants restent bien
niché dans leur siège et le dos de la
banque est devant et coussiné leur
répond qu'arrive-t-il quand on renverser
la boîte à oeufs ou qu'on se met à la
secouer sans son couvercle et que tous
les heures à voile par tous les pères
pointe du doigt l'étude de transports
canada de 1984 ou plutôt ce qui n'était
pas dans l'étude
au canada on avait omis d' analyser les
accidents les plus graves
c'est à dire les collisions latérales et
les tonneaux on n'avait pas non plus
testé les ceintures diagonale dans
l'efficacité a été prouvée dans les
voitures sauf arrivée ne ment pas si on
se base sur les faits on ne peut que
constater ce que tous les parents savent
déjà les ceintures de sécurité sauve des
vies
[Musique]
après la pause des preuves que les
ceintures fonctionne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si transports canada ne recommande pas
le port de la ceinture dans les autobus
ce centre d'évaluation tente de prouver
que c'est une erreur de ne pas emporter
c'est ici que nous rangeons nos
dispositifs décès nos mannequins qui
sert van houtte est james johnson et
directeur chez imi en indiana
une des plus importantes entreprises de
simulation d'impact
depuis plusieurs années l'entreprise
fabrique des ceintures à trois points
d'ancrage destiné aux autobus scolaire
ils les ont testés ici même dans les
scénarios d'accidents graves par la
majorité des essais
les mannequins reste en place ceux qui
ne partent pas de ceinture sont éjectés
de l'autobus la compartimentation ne
protège pas suffisamment la compagnie a
conçu un système de sièges coussiné
combinée à des ceintures à trois points
de compartimentation ne protège pas dans
les cas de collision latérale et de
tonneaux
c'est ce type d'accident qui entraîne
les blessures graves et les décès les
ceintures abdominales et diagonales font
une énorme différence
cette idée fait du chemin dans certaines
localités du texas
cet homme supervise une flotte de 500
autobus transportant quotidiennement 23
mille écoliers
ils portent tous la ceinture de sécurité
évidemment la question se pose combien
coûte toutes ses ceintures et dans sa
présente à peu près sept à dix mille
dollars de plus par autobus neufs boîte
justement comment peut-on mettre un prix
sur la vie d'un enfant une de stmicro et
jonas save the beach art
au québec le prix serait d'au minimum
douze mille dollars pour un autobus
neufs qui coûte lui autour de 110 mille
une préoccupation majeure pour les
transporteurs est ce que ça vous a
paradé raisonnable il y aura plus de
marges de profit et ce moment alors il
est peut-être des entreprises qui
risquent d'être sérieuses difficultés
financières
mais encore là je veux pas jouer la
carte financière sur sa sécurité
et vous l'avez vous me posez la question
[Musique]
le jour se lève et les autobus scolaires
partout en amérique du nord se prépare à
prendre la route au québec
un demi million d'élèves monteront dans
huit mille autobus sans ceinture
mais aux états unis de plus en plus de
commissions scolaires exige des autobus
neufs
munis de ceintures à trois points
il semble qu'ici les enfants soient
capables d'attaché la ceinture de
sécurité ils le font tous les jours
[Musique]
pour vous
des arguments qui ne semble convaincre
ni les chauffeurs - mon opinion sexy
arrive un pépin majeur que l'autobus
tombe sur le côté si on a 40 ceinture a
défait à auxerre est bloqué c'est là que
ça public dangereux ni les transporteurs
scolaires au québec on a un conducteur
d'autobus en navarre qui selon les
règlements de nouveaux pop quitter son
poste de travail son poste de conduite
il ya aux primaires on parle de teulat
deux au maximum 72 enfants comment il
peut s'assurer lui en avant que les
enfants sont tous attachés correctement
vous voyez les auteurs des maquettes de
part son miroir est pas capable voir si
un enfant très attachée qui était
responsable à savoir si l'enfant était
très chaud mais pour ces élèves des
laurentides la ceinture tombe sous le
sens
particulièrement pour les plus petits
dupuis en sciences ou en externe souvent
sécurité pourtant transports canada
insiste pour dire que ce n'est pas
nécessaire c'est bien ce qui inquiète
rade uci o'hara témoin d'un accident
d'autobus scolaires sur la rive sud de
montréal en 2016
ça s'est passé à mon arrivée j'ai vu
l'autobus scolaire qui était déjà
quand tu es sur le côté tout le monde
était est un petit peu pêle mêle je
dirais dans l'autobus scolaire et j'ose
croire qu'au moment où ça s'est produit
lyon de vue forcément ce s'écraser le
l'autre un petit peu le bon samaritain a
ouvert les portes de sa fourgonnette aux
jeunes et branly pas de blessures
sérieuses cette fois ci mais la
confirmation d'une de ses plus grandes
craintes
effectivement ça m'est passé par la tête
qu'arriverait-il aux causes hook
c'est que monsieur triaud haras est
propriétaire d'une garderie privée
les sorties à la ferme ou au jardin
botanique se font en autobus scolaire ça
reste pas toujours en place les enfants
ça bouge dans l'autobus scolaire
ils ont une certaine liberté notamment
parce qu'ils sont pas attachés ci-haut
vraiment un accident un impact frontal
latéral
c'est sûr que ses enfants le resteront
poissy selon moi personnellement je
pense qu'ils savoir voler dans l'autobus
vous ne faites pas de sortir l'autobus
scolaire l'hiver non en fait non aux
sorties s'il était question de sécurité
donc ils sont limités un peu les risques
les enfants les parents et les
propriétaires des garderies se posent
les mêmes questions depuis des décennies
depuis cette fameuse étude de transports
canada affirmant que les ceintures
pouvait être dangereuse
[Musique]
s'il y avait eu des ceintures de
sécurité jenny serait probablement resté
dans l'autobus
c'est là où j'étais assise quinine clark
avait 14 ans quand il a survécu à
l'accident qui a coûté la vie à djénine
au bol il était assis devant elle et
comme jenny il a lui aussi été éjecté de
l'autobus
les blessures se sont produites quand
j'ai été projeté de telus il s'en est
tiré avec un traumatisme crânien des
côtes cassées et des vertèbres
fracturées
jenny a été moins chanceuses sa mère
passe devant le lieu de l'accident
presque tous les jours
il aura fallu cette tragédie en 2008
pour braquer à nouveau les projecteurs
sur la question des ceintures et forcé
l'alberta à se pencher sur la sécurité
dans les autobus scolaires
on a cru pendant un bref moment que les
ceintures deviendrait enfin obligatoire
mais la vie de transports canada contre
les ceintures a fait pencher la balance
et l'alberta a abandonné la bataille
[Musique]
au retour une étude caché qui contredit
les directives de transports canada
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
depuis les dix dernières années le
nombre de blessures subies dans les
accidents impliquant des autobus
scolaires ne cesse de croître
la position de transports canada ne fait
plus l'unanimité aux états unis de
nombreux organismes s'entendent pour
dire que les ceintures de sécurité
sauvent des vies et protéger les
passagers
mais chez nous transports canada reste
campé sur ses positions
les positions parfois contredite par ses
propres employés
co dirige le laboratoire de recherche de
transports canada il y a neuf ans en
2010 elle a mené une autre étude pour le
compte de transports canada elle y avait
conclu que le rembourrage des banquettes
n'était pas efficace dans les cas de
collision latérale
il ne prévient pas suffisamment les
blessures graves
son étude démontre donc le contraire de
la thèse soutenue par son employeur
transports canada
mais l'étude est resté caché jusqu'à ce
que nos collègues de la cible ici tu
demandes à l'obtenir en 2010 vous avez
mené une étude pour transports canada
oui quelle était la conclusion d'études
les ceintures de sécurité empêchent les
passagers d'être éjecté de l'autobus
ça démontre que la compartimentation
n'est pas adéquat pour les collisions
latérales et les tonneaux de satan rendu
cette étude publique je ne crois pas au
sujet des mesures de sécurité à
instaurer dans les autobus scolaire
suivante il cody ceci l'installation des
ceintures de sécurité est un premier pas
que les autobus scolaires devraient
avoir des ceintures should be da c'est
une première étape
vous parlez de première étape n'est ce
pas mieux que rien
bad connaissent pas suffisant pour les
rendre obligatoires
une fois de plus je ne peux pas me
prononcer sur cette question il faudrait
parler à ceux qui décident des
politiques
je ne peux pas répondre à cette question
l'équipe de siby ci a sollicité une
entrevue auprès des patrons de madame
chilcot sans succès mais le grand patron
lui a réagi à ces nouvelles informations
j'ai donné l'instruction à mon
département aujourd'hui de regarder en
profondeur toute cette question des
ceintures de sécurité
les autobus scolaires et j'ai hâte de
voir les résultats
en attendant les résultats le ministre
garneau s'est imposé une étape de plus
il veut consulter les provinces avant de
prendre sa décision
je veux la prendre le plus tôt possible
mais on est dans une confédération
travaille avec les provinces et oui vous
avez raison j'ai le droit de l'imposer
mais on veut le faire de la bonne façon
une autre tragédie avait forcé le
ministère à réagir rapidement
l'accident d'autocar qui a décimé
l'équipe de hockey de humboldt l'an
dernier avait provoqué un changement de
position j'ai transports canada les
ceintures de sécurité seront
obligatoires dans les autocars dès 2020
dans ce cas là il y avait des ceintures
dans l'autocar mais les joueurs ne les
portez pas en ontario l'ex-première
ministre quartier lwin qui siège comme
député ne veut pas attendre transports
canada elle propose de légiférer au
niveau provincial pour rendre
obligatoire la ceinture dans les autobus
scolaires
[Applaudissements]
il existe de nouvelles preuves qu'ils
n'étaient pas disponibles auparavant
l'ontario peut agir seul mais il ya les
autres provinces les territoires
on devrait avoir une norme pour
l'ensemble du pays allez vous révisez
vos positions on sait pas on nous a
répondu ce boulot je pense qu'après
siens transports canada mais on va
s'assurer nous que si jamais sa voix le
on va faire en sorte que nos membres
respectent les régions ça deviendra un
choix de société et le gouvernement
devra faire en sorte de mettre en place
les mesures nécessaires pour que y ait
des instances pertinentes ou des autobus
s'appartient pas juste aux transporteurs
ça appartient aux sous gouverneur à ce
crime
un gouvernement du québec qui ne semble
pas pressée d'agir
le cabinet du ministre du transport
françois bonnardel nous a assuré que la
sécurité était importante pour le
gouvernement mais que pour l'instant le
ministère allait laisser le fédéral
entamé la réflexion
c'est le genre de non réponse qui ne
surprend plus gabriel gélinas au
lendemain de son accident d'autobus à
mont-saint-hilaire il y a deux ans il
avait profité d'une rencontre au collège
pour poser des questions moi j'ai posé
directement au ministre au maire pour
1.6 gdi pourquoi on ne met pas de
ceinture de sécurité dans les autobus
parce que je me suis dit vu qu'on a
basculé sur le côté si nous étions
attachés on aurait évité une tonne de
blessure et qu'est ce qu'on t'a répondu
oui c'est heureusement rien depuis plus
de 34 ans transports canada rejette
l'idée de rendre obligatoires les
ceintures de sécurité dans les autobus
scolaires
sachant maintenant qu'on avait mené
d'autres études il y a lieu de se poser
la question
aurait-on pu prévenir les nombreuses
blessures et les décès comme celui de
jenny on avait déjà les je t'aime du nid
méchas
en septembre à innisfail en ontario un
autre accident impliquant un autobus
scolaire
deux élèves ont subi des fractures en
novembre à saint jérôme
un autre bus s'est renversé dans une
bretelle d'autoroute trois élèves ont
été hospitalisés évidemment aucun des
deux n'était équipé de ceintures de
sécurité
[Musique]
c'est un dossier qui va sûrement évoluer
au cours des prochains mois parce que le
ministre des transports du canada
vaud propose aux provinces de créer un
comité pour revoir toute la question des
ceintures de sécurité à bord des autobus
scolaires
on espère que vous avez apprécié les
reportages de ce soir au nom de toute
l'équipe merci beaucoup d'avoir été lent
et on se retrouve la semaine prochaine
pour une autre enquête
[Musique]